this is gone boy get that booty booty ah
yeah you want a history books yeah what
I'm doing
I'm Charlie you know you guys bend right
you know use me okay my name is Jan
spread
the goal of this is we're supposed to
find peeps right yeah and I'm gonna load
in your butt yeah look at him
so he's pretty much got a kamikaze is I
think he's this one nope
what are you talking about I think
you're this one
dammit I think you're this one didn't
explode and ever they're so sneaky
really good detectives I don't know I
think you did are we are we looking at
you know are you talking about I think
you're you what you sell me oh I saw
some kind of graphical glitch was like I
knew it is not fair you guys are two
versus one that's true then you're just
a plant
hey dude oh you got me I got it oh my
god oh and I respawn okay all right well
behind you [ __ ] - oh it's gonna get
over this too slow
you know what Ken you could have helped
me out there a little bit while I was
trying to decipher the rule no real book
newbie like this it's not so late uh Oh
God
oh hi hello I'm gonna fellow my fellow
playing note no I don't like book no I
don't have some how much get out of here
you freaking plant damn oh we make that
noise when I run Jesus you hear that
[ __ ] yes it's very serious
okay this is a good game this is a good
fun time to play with your friends and
family
thank you David thank you he said Yolo
so it's not offensive get heroin she's
destroying it I thought that was you
making the noise and Skype but it's just
no in flames
oh sure know what the [ __ ]
okay it's fine practice your book game
you you need not tell you okay to read
more books hello
don't do that hey stop it
what do you do again yeah go get boy no
I'm all right kid
well pincer maneuver oh yeah him I don't
see you guys right he's right
[ __ ] Snipes oh yeah you try to play
it off I don't even see right now
oh yeah it's right click I don't miss
you got again got oh hello
I saw it happen it was terrible alright
should we play until the first team to
get 10 points done okay
alright cuz you yet oh good good got him
so we're at six year at seven sounds
good sounds fair yeah now it's at eight
yeah hey hey right right there I see you
move it oh yeah what are you doing yeah
these are the ride I don't know I can't
jump okay I can't jump it yes oh yeah
good it like okay it's 7 to 9 our guys
spawn
he's over there is over there but you
saw me what
I [ __ ] knew you would do it [ __ ]
knew you would do that host advantage
alright that's enough for this math then
okay you got our 10 kills
um all right okay you guys are both
plants versus me no not fair at all it
is fair now you get to taste it where
are you guys uh we're not inside oh
really
yeah huh interesting it is interesting
isn't it no way you got me [ __ ] you try
scary [ __ ] on me I've never been so
scared my plan yeah okay maybe one time
okay that's fair one time is fair where
the oh they have Monty Python samples
you hear that wait
oh if you come over here there's a bunch
of those read more books way yeah way I
keep going where you're going Nick look
all these books I feel like this is a
time well there goes our [ __ ] trap we
don't anything else can you sneak up on
me very happy
are you doing shut up wishes
can we get look yes [ __ ] yeah I saw
where you spawn I saw come here no wait
I gotta get one second you read a book
lose very violent we appease bear where
are you at Petey pie
yeah paper Budi Budi pie
40 pi this value here where you put it
back put hold it port 40 PI put it put
it Rudy Rudy patootie PI booty booty
booty what he had 40 big booty pi hmm
big big booty ho P booty Judy back buddy
big big burger me only big burger with
me is he is he is he alive I don't know
is he around
he's around I could even breathing can
you you sure that's not just us with
bated breath sorry guys yesterday the
breath I can't well I won't leave you
anymore okay
you weren't even here we were looking we
are you serious yeah do it
yes so it's time we you said some great
things
why are you doing over there I don't
know I don't really think you know what
you want me to do
I got damnit I don't like this well you
could be surrounded right now I'm not
fooling you or play up God what are you
laughing at
where's the other one where's the other
one
and who knows who knows where the other
one is in the end doesn't it maybe only
be
do you like plants are you guys doing
over there oh hi premature exploited
nice that's nice I'm gonna sample that
as well correct
oh god I'm oh boy
get that booty booty yeah you want a
history books ya wanna do Johnny you
know you guys wind right you know you
use me
my name is you can spread [ __ ] it did
the noise oh guys the best part
damn it oh [ __ ] hey if he looks look at
here where hey Felix look out I'm in
another road sniper [ __ ] you just like
me I got prettier than more this night
me come on give it to me you can do it
heaven loser gotcha don't even move I'll
give you a free one
ah no how would I miss that hey hey
Popeye yeah what you're not here are you
what what what's funny are you getting
doing are you doing something 45 all
right what hey hey wait I got Ken
now come on finally damn it I ain't
looking over the ledge it's like big oh
hey Lane oh my god I don't have any ever
go no I hear all right yay oh my god
this is intense man ah okay
I never mind we did it yeah alright this
looks oh god okay so I'm a hunter it's
cry you're a survivor
it's insider hi-yah oh god it's just me
versus you both oh god I never met a
woman with a beautiful face like yours
kiss me
read a book first okay God what's wrong
with your [ __ ] hands man and what
that look look at your hands
level I broke it in an accident in the
war that's why I'm to this I don't like
this I mean I better read this book
check forget what it is hmm apparently
it's a chaotic monkey lives and bushes
it's a chaotic monkey fanfiction
whatever yes explodes if I wasn't quiet
hurry skin with a lot of stroke a
confident pose I had luck what the [ __ ]
he couldn't take it
he couldn't take it can't take it
anymore you guys look at a cloud the
cloud if you have it sounds like yeah
what'd you do this is a huge map is it
yeah you're not anywhere near either was
he able to get apart well now turn
around
and go over here go where you're facing
currently say stop stop
turn to your left and then so glad that
work um excuse me Sarah have you heard
of our one true Lord Savior book you
should totally read one all right oh no
no please just isn't five minutes but I
have to say okay talk okay so this is a
book right and some books it like this
book yeah man selling they burned the
book are they like I'm good fried egg
the book came back
uh-huh I just like hey uh-huh me and was
that ah
you